there's stronger getting loose for the
houston astros this evening the record
stands at three and two so chew on it
first valdez now deals with kinder
philippa
runner goes
and the throw down to second not in time
chew
with his fifth stolen base
there's a little bouncer
just to the side of the mound vaudez
slings it past first that will allow chu
to come in from third base
and connor falefa goes to second on the
error
and so the rangers
jump right on valdez for the one nothing
lead this first and third situation now
can nick solac find a way
this one hit hard out to left field and
that one will go off
the crawford box facing
kinder philip is in
gallow to third base solak drives in the
run and it's two nothing the right
hander luis garcia two seam fastball
he's got the slider the split finger the
four-seam fastball as well goes two and
two on springer and he swings and misses
a strikeout to start the bottom of the
first there are the base runners
kyle tucker
and he strikes him out swinging two
strikeouts in the inning for garcia so
he does his job so far jordan lyles has
retired all four batters since coming in
out of the bullpen he got first and
second one out middle your lineup coming
up brantley facing jordan lyles this
ball driven to right field pretty deep
gallo going back he's near the fence he
reaches up and he puts the ball away in
front of the fence brantley misses a
home run by about five feet euler trying
to make that happen here with two outs
on the ground to short andrews will flip
it to the second baseman solac and the
astros leave two more they did so in the
first and now the third he's laid off
base runner for the rangers in the
fourth two first
altuve down to the ground starts this
turn of the double play correa finishes
it again
what a right arm from carlos correa
this is real time
[Applause]
so he walks tavares with two outs guzman
who's over one tonight
we'll hit hard down the first base line
and down into that corner tavares can
run they'll wave him around third he'll
score without a throw guzman going for
three and he'll jog in with a stand up
triple
three-nothing rangers
rangers with a three-nothing lead as we
go to the bottom of the fifth inning
jordan lyles three shutouts so far toro
the first hitter
a foul
and what a play
in foul ground by kiner falefa what a
difference it makes for him to go in
with confidence
and make that sliding catch tremendous
now correa bats with runners on the
corners representing a tying run
tucker on the go ground ball base hit
altuve scores easily tucker will hold up
carlos correa with an rbi single the
astros on the board it's now a three to
one game good two strike two out hitting
right there by carlos correa now josh
redick bats
how about that catch brian knight a
little bare hand play on the breaking
ball that
lyles through after time have been
called
to tell all of his colleagues that he
caught a big league
pitcher's pitch bare-handed
until they see the video
reddick looking to try and come through
with a big two out rbi here here it
comes and a swing and a miss he got him
redick strikes out the inning is done
and the astros held to one run in the
inning bottom half of the seventh inning
astros down two they have two on with
nobody out in the top of the order due
up against nick goody the new pitcher
michael brantley is over two with a walk
tonight
brandley sends one down the line and
right this ball is hooking and this ball
is gone off the fair pole michael
bradley three-run homer gives the astros
a 4-3 lead
got another mistake and did not miss
that one
uncle mike picking up the boys
first inherited runs aloud all year by
nick goody and he cannot believe
he made that pitch he was ahead of the
count and then brantley gets it with two
strikes
ninth inning andrews leading it off 3-1
and that ball hit well
deep out to left it is gone
this game is tied
elvis andrews with a solo shot into the
crawford boxes and we've got a new game
astros 4-4 game here as we head to the
bottom half of the ninth inning abraham
toro do up
ground ball towards the right side into
right field for a base hit the astros
have the winning run on base in the
ninth as abraham toro with back-to-back
base hits mark team might lay one down
gets the bunt down good one the pitcher
hernandez has one play he'll make that
to first and the astros winning run
abraham toro now at second base counts
three and two after springer got ahead
3-0
and that one's grounded to third diving
stopped down there by kinder philippa
he's sort of first
pulled down and the tag applied to get
springer what a play at first base to
get that huge second out great play full
extension throws a little high
fernandez can get altuve the rangers
would have the top of the order coming
up
payoff
bouncer third base
keiner falefa has it good stretch by the
baseball player rivera at first let's go
to the tent the ghost runner out there
heinemann is at third base now with one
away
oh
by taylor
and here comes the go head run how about
that
was that a let's go from scott einemann
not a boy
so two out kind of fluffa on via an
error and gallo
gallo bunting
and maldonado throws it away
way down the right field line
kinder fulfa coming to the plate here
comes a throw not in time
and a huge insurance run for the rangers
they lead six to four
so michael brandley who was the hero in
this game he will bat here as the tying
run
brantley lines one into right center
field that'll be a base hit jose altuve
being waved around the throw will be cut
off
and altuve scores to make it six to five
michael brantley with a four rbi knight
all of a sudden the tying run at first
and the winning run at home plate
real right-handed hitter crowding the
plate waiting on the 2-1 pitch here it
is it's bounced up the middle elvis has
it steps on second for one to throw the
first double play kyle tucker represents
the last hope for houston
in the air
left field toward the line long run and
heinemann gets to it to make the play
this one is over and so the rangers with
their first extra innings victory of the
season
they take the opener in houston six to
five